2020万人おめでとうございます
ありがとうございますようやく行けました
こんにちははじめしゃとうです皆さん知っ
ている人もいるかわかんないんですけども
僕こう見えて
ぬいぐるみ好きなんすよ
なんかビジネスとかじゃなくてちょっとガ
チでそのなんか可愛らしいぬいぐるみと
いうかま僕で有名なやつと言ったらこれと
かですねもうめちゃくちゃこの感じが好き
なんですよわかりますそんな可愛くもない
あそんな可愛くないって言ったら失礼です
けどちょっとそのなんて言うんでしょう
若干編というか気も可愛いみたいな
ぬいぐるみがめちゃくちゃ好きで多分俺
YouTube始めた初期かなもう初期の
頃からずっとこのカエルとかに関しては
持っててちょっとこのカエルは
めちゃくちゃ好きで日々動画に作らせて
いただいてますしなんかめっちゃ出ない
やつもあるし取ってこいつこれとか
めちゃくちゃレアだった気がするんすよね
これすごい目がさ見て金になってるんよ
2万5000円です結構このカエルの
イメージはじめしゃちょー昔から見てる人
なんかあると思うんですけども
今回今回やばいものを買わせていただき
ました
でかいなんかネットとかでカエルのグッズ
とはぬいぐるみなんかいいのないかなって
よく見てるんですけども見たことないもう
見たことないものがメルカリで出品されて
てもう見たことないのが売っててこれ買わ
ないかと思って買わせていただきました
メルカリで絶対売ってないもうネットとか
だと絶対売ってないものが見てくれると
言っててすげえなと思って買った
早速開けていきましょうさすがに貰い物だ
から丁寧に開けさせていただきますね
これはすごいよそれも何種類か入って
るって感じですねあまずこういうね
きっとカエルが好きだったのかなフリュー
仕様のカエルさんとか可愛いね手袋までし
てあすごいちっちゃいのある
ちっちゃすぎんか
ちっちゃすぎんかこのこんなこんな
ちっちゃいのもあるの初めて知ったから
程よいサイズのもあるんだね可愛いおーで
かなりでかいぞ俺の顔よりでかいもんか
これさあ
本命です正直ここまではお遊びといっても
過言ではない今回僕が欲しかったのは
こいつですいくぞ
やばいやばい
うはははもう
[音楽]
顔で
顔でこのサイズよいやいやもうでかすぎ
でしょいやいやいやいやいやうわうわうわ
うわー
[音楽]
俺並にでかいすごいなぁ
はいというわけで僕が欲しかったのは
こちらの
超特大何cmだったっけこのサイズの
カエルは世の中で見たことない2mだ2M
のカービットメルカリでまあいろいろ
セットなんですけども12万円ぐらいで
売っておりました多分なんですけども
世の中に出回ってないんだろうなこの
サイズは
人やあなたその大きさも人じゃん人
デカすぎんだってこれ立たせたらさもう
全然ま2mあるな
呼び出したく
なっちゃうしこうやったらマジでもう人間
をおんぶしてる感覚あるねいやもうこれと
かもめっちゃ可愛いしさこうちっちゃいの
俺見たことなかったしこれもでかいまここ
ら辺は俺がよく知ってるサイズ感なんです
けどもこれねまあお風呂ということで
ちょっと人気は入ってるんですけども全然
綺麗だし
結構古いものだと思うんですけども前使っ
てたからすげえ大事にしてたんだなって
思います
ねえこわはいというわけで今日の動画
何しようかと言いますとこれが多分基本
サイズなんですよ基本サイズ昔から僕が
使ってるのは多分このサイズなんですけど
もまあもう遠近法でこの距離でやっと同じ
大きさこんだけ違うからねこれが基本
サイズだと思うんですけども
多分
俺の周りの人たちってそんなにカエルの
人形の大きさなんて気にしてないんですよ
というわけで今日はこの子のサイズが
だんだん変わっていったらいつ気づくのか
時やっていきたいと思いますまあ最終手段
こっちなんすけどこれでさすがに気づか
ないのはマジでやばいこれはさすがに
気づくと思うんですけどもなんか
ちょいちょいね大きさ変わってって結構5
パターンぐらいあると思うんですよ大きく
なったり小さくなったりできると思うん
ですけども素直にこのサイズのカエルが
世の中に存在すること知らないと思うん
です普通にびっくりすると思うんですけど
もどれだけ普段帰るに目を向けている
身の周りにシェアを広めているのか今日は
確かめていきたいと思いますでは
[音楽]
喉乾いた
喉乾いて水飲みたいかもしれない
水なんかあるかね上にあったっけ
そこにあるでしょ
えマジで
[音楽]
水っていいよねもうね一番ね
グリーン袋ってあるっけ
ゴミ袋
ん
マジかそんなごめんこの中で
パーシーの動画うん
助けです
片付けちょっとだけしたくてあー確かにね
鼻をきれいにしたくて何がいらなくて何が
必要かな
ネット繋がってくかな
やるちょっとそれだけお願いしたいかも今
うん
[音楽]
あそっかな
腕立て札
おーいいね
何の動画ね
いいのいいね
ハイキング見たいはい
筋量
[音楽]